[Music]
dinosaurs and giant monsters are why we
created this channel in the first place
and what better topic to showcase than
dinosaur kaiju of course this isn't
related to jurassic dinosaurs and
hybrids as even as big as they might
look they are not in the least bit in
the kaiju scale chart here we will take
a look at 10 of the most biggest famous
and powerful kaiju that have hit the big
screen and all of them are of
dinosaurian origins so subscribe if you
haven't already and now let's get down
to it
number 10 read osaurus the radiosaurus
is a fictional giant carnivorous
man-eating lizard-like monster dinosaur
from the 1953 american film the beast
from twenty thousand fathoms it is the
sole surviving member of a species of a
lizard-like dinosaur that lived past the
kt extinction 66 million years ago the
species lived as far back as the middle
paleolithic period it has razor sharp
teeth and claws that allows it to do
severe damage to its attackers its skin
is impervious to gunfire and even tank
shells it walks on all fours and looks
more like a komodo dragon than a
dinosaur it is around 60 feet tall 200
feet or 61 meters long and weighs 500
tons
number 9 the paleosaurus this
paleosaurus was a creature which
appeared in the low budget 1959 creature
feature the giant behemoth the
paleosaurus was a huge quadripedal
dinosaur with a mouthful of viciously
sharp teeth a dark green color thick
scales and a mouthful of sharp teeth oh
yeah i just said that it emitted a
continual aura of radioactivity that was
harmful to everything and interfered
with electrical equipment it could also
discharge electrical balls in the same
way as an electric eel could this
paleosaurus was 60 to 70 feet tall 200
feet or 61 meters long and weighed 1500
tons
number 8 the gorosaurus
toho introduced this monster this giant
dinosaur kaiju in the 1967 touhou film
king kong escapes he is a modern
descendant of the dinosaur allosaurus
gorosaurus is a great dinosaur with
noticeable scaly bumps on his skin he
possesses a bipedal stance strong legs
short but muscular arms and a large head
as well as a row of triangular plates
running down his back on the tip of his
tail he has a type of a club outgrowth
this kaiju was 35 meters or 115 feet
tall
55 meters or 180 feet long and weighed 8
000 tons
he was a villain in king kong escapes
but was a protagonist in destroy all
monsters that godzilla movie
number 7 baragon
baragon was a prehistoric reptile from
the mesozoic era who survived the kt
extinction 66 million years ago by
burrowing underground and subsisting on
uranium reserves in the earth
baragon originally appeared in the film
frankenstein vs baragon where he was
awakened by the noises of a factory
nearby
baragon looks more like a mammal slash
dinosaur hybrid and as such he is on
this list
his most distinguishable traits are his
two big ears that can flap and close
around his eyes and that rhino-like horn
on his nose
in gmk godzilla millennium 2001 and that
movie baragon was one of the guardian
masters of japan and was killed by
godzilla
he was relatively smaller at around 30
meters or 100 feet tall and 10 000 tons
in weight
number six varen varen is an ancient
reptilian slash dinosaur-like creature
which lived from the triassic through
the cretaceous periods varying escaped
extinction and lived for millions of
years at the bottom of a lake in japan
as a relic of the dinosaur varanas
patter they live in the mesozoic era it
is equipped with thin flying membranes
between its arms and can soar in the sky
it has hind legs which are big and can
expand into wings to fly at mark's
speeds it looks a lot like anguirus with
its spiky armored back and at times seen
to walk on all foes in its w film of the
same name varen it is 50 meters or 164
feet tall 80 meters or 262 feet long and
weighed 15 000 tons
number five titanosaurus this kaiju is a
giant aquatic dinosaur monster that
appeared in the terror of make a
godzilla movie titanosaurus is an
aquatic animal and can breathe and swim
at speeds of up to 200 kilometers per
hour underwater
the monster is physically capable of
matching godzilla's power it is a deep
sea creature with fins on board of its
tail
and back and two tiny ones on both sides
of its head
there are also two antennas on the top
of its head
he features a bipedal physique with a
long neck a snout that looks like a
raptor
and short muscular arms his scales are
red in color with an orange underbelly
and neck and this dinosaur kaiju was 60
meters or 200 feet tall 100 meters or
328 feet long and weighed 30 000 tons
number four rodin
yeah this one isn't actually a dinosaur
kaiju but a pterosaur so close yet so
far away a close cousin to dinosaurs
okay which we will include in this list
rodan made his first appearance
alongside godzilla in the 1964 godzilla
film ghidorah the three-headed monster
ronin resembles a large pterosaur that
walks upright on two legs rodan
generally has either brown or burgundy
skin with spiky chests and two horns on
the back of its head his biggest version
is the fire demon titan of the
monsterverse in this stake he was 47
meters or 154 feet tall has a wingspan
of 871 feet or 265.5 meters and weighs
in at more than 39 000 tons
number three anguirus
this one is a famous rival turned best
friend of godzilla like godzilla
anguirus managed to survive into the
modern day by lying dormant somewhere
presumably underwater before being
awakened and irradiated by nuclear bombs
in the 1950s anguirus walks mostly on
all foes but can be bipedal as well the
most recognizable features of this
dinosaur kaiju is its armored back lined
with rows of spikes like a porcupine it
is a descendant of the ankilosaurus it
has been seen in the showa era up to the
millennium era of films in final wars it
was 40 meters or 131 feet tall on all
foes but 90 meters or 295 feet tall went
bipedal it was 160 meters or 525 feet
long and weighed 60 000 tons
number two agra ogra is an ancient
dinosaur kaiju that originally featured
in the british film gorgo in 1961. her
skin is dark green in color with a paler
underbelly ogre has a pair of tiny fins
on the sides of her head as well as big
muscular hands
ogre's attacks are simple relying on
strong strength and endurance which
means biting scratching punching and
slamming into things are her only
attacks she is enormous standing between
70 to 76 meters or 232 250 feet tall her
weight is unknown but even her smaller
son gorgo who was five times shorter at
around 50 feet tall weighed in at 27 500
tons so she must be over 100 000 tons
and number one godzilla and yes of
course we have the king of the monsters
godzilla has always been thought of and
originally designed to be a dinosaur
kaiju with atomic powers in one of his
origin stories he was a descendant of a
species called the godzillosaurus which
was way bigger than dinosaurs even in
the ancient past godzilla needs no
description we all know what he looks
like by now with that bipedal stance
long tail dorsal blades atomic breath in
his biggest form he is more than 1 000
feet or 300 meters tall
1 800 feet or 550 meters long and
weighed in more than 100 000 tons
yet the monster vs godzilla which is
smaller in size
weighs in more than him with gvk's
iteration coming in at 164 000 tons and
this is the biggest dinosaur kaiju
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind q family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam